[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is my car
it's a Toyota 100 that's been remade to
look like an fj60
never been much of a car guy but when I
saw these old Toyota's I kind of fell in
love with them I still really like this
car like
it looks good people kept saying they're
too big for Tokyo but hey no problem so
far
so I was given the opportunity to go
off-road with it I had no idea what to
expect but I was so excited
spoilers it didn't go so great oh
no
oh no
[Music]
oh this is actually it actually went
amazing good morning going off-roading
today with the Toyota
got a couple people joining as well I'm
very excited for it should be really fun
we got a two hour drive ahead of us so
let's go
[Music]
all right
here we are
intense this off-roading track had a
bunch of different obstacles and rated
different Stars based on how difficult
they were what could possibly go wrong
we started off with me taking off in the
first track all right let's go boys
wait where's he going this is it it
feels like like like little kids playing
with their toy cars
go slower sorry go faster oh yeah you
gotta go faster
I can't see where we're going that's the
boy we're in the trees
it definitely go slow try to be as
gentle as possible
oh
oh
is it back into the car gone we're good
yeah my [ __ ] God
I'm not even driving it's just like
sliding
[ __ ] that's incredible okay you gotta
center we're gonna die you're all right
not crazy
whoa
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
oh my God
yeah that's that it's not slow
as well slow
literally a [ __ ] theme park ride
he said later we'll do more advanced
that I thought that was the advance
go single Diamond up next is Double
Diamond we of course took turns everyone
got to try it's way scary in the bank
God no way right right turn right turn
right roll over
oh that's so cool so on the V Grove
obstacle it's really difficult to not
hit your back bumper on the way out I
hit it but it's my car so it's okay but
Kevin
I'll never forgive this
I need to concentrate oh he got it we
got it we got it Kevin you got it you
just ripped him nothing
oh
[Laughter]
there we go next up we got to ride with
one of the professional drivers and oh
boy
that was what happened
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
wow these guys are crazy that was the
wineless ride ever you're next I'm shy
[Laughter]
wow
after that horrifying experience we took
one more lap and we saw this mud pile
wait no and we got the thumbs up to go
through it
[Music]
no
oh no
oh no
oh this is actually fun wait this is a
picture moment oh no
oh [ __ ]
what he wants a picture oh honestly I
felt really embarrassed by this what
have I done
giving them a gift they insisted that I
was going to be the one who towed the
car out which is a terrible idea because
I never done anything like that either
before
you try
oh
oh my God
[Music]
oh no you tore the bumper off why would
you do that
foreign
oh my God
oh my God
[Music]
work
very strong coast rap uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
remember what I told you about the tire
that's what it's for we need to ruin
three cars
all right we have one other option I
guess
good job keep going yeah keep
keep
[Music]
one more
[Music]
we kept trying so many times
[Music]
I couldn't tell what I was doing I
honestly didn't think we were gonna get
it out how's it going Felix
you have no idea
but we kept trying and it looks like
they were making some progress
[Music]
go go
yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God
it did not look like that oh
yeah
why assess the damage
um
you might need to heal up a bay go fix
it no problem we gave her a clean and
then it was time to head back home good
splash
big thanks to Alan and Kevin and will
for joining me and of course Flex for
setting this up they're the ones that
sell the Toyota's I don't think I ever
would have done this if it weren't for
their invitation so yeah and don't worry
she's fixed now they took care of it
maybe you're cringing because we totally
wrecked the cars I'm usually really
precious about my stuff but it was so
fun to just I don't know be a kid and
just mess around for a day I loved it
such a great memory and I'm so glad I'm
able to share it with you guys thanks
for watching this video
that's it